vitrines brisées magasins pillés une
deuxième nuit d'émeutes a secoué les
pays bas ce lundi soir une réaction au
couvre feu mis en place très mal reçue
par la population
les néerlandais expriment leur colère
avec de violents affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre qui
ont procédé à plus de 300 arrestations
en deux jours rotterdam eindhoven
amsterdam
les maires de plusieurs grandes villes
ont annoncé l'instauration de mesures
d'urgence pour empêcher l'émergence de
nouveaux troubles sous pression
également le nord de l'italie
les habitants de lombardie étaient
nombreux ce lundi à réclamer la
démission du gouverneur de la région
attilio fontana est accusé d'être
responsable d'une erreur de calcul
portant sur le nombre d'infections au
colis 19 des erreurs statistiques qui
ont valu à la lombardie d'être confiné à
tort une erreur pas sans conséquence
pour une région qui a perdu 26 mille de
ses citoyens au printemps dernier il se
soucie juste du marché financier il ne
se soucie pas de la santé
nous estimons que la santé est un droit
humain nous sommes réunis ici
aujourd'hui parce que 600 millions
d'euros des citoyens de la lombardie ont
été gaspillés en raison de mauvaises
données
ils doivent donc démissionner nous
sommes libres
le mécontentement se fait aussi entendre
dans la capitale espagnole un slogan
sous le signe de la colère et d'un
ras-le-bol généralisé
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
défilé dans les rues de madrid ce
week-end objectif dénoncer des mesures
dites liberticide imposée par le
gouvernement notamment un couvre-feu
nocturne et une restriction de la
mobilité entre régions lors de cette
manifestation ni masque ni distanciation
social provoqué pour mieux protester les
madrilènes n'ont pas peur des mots et
parle d'une dictature mondiale engendrée
par le cos vide 19 même image au
danemark où un groupe radical a organisé
une manifestation contre les
restrictions durant laquelle plusieurs
arrestations musclées ont eu lieu
des images d'une rare violence qui
témoigne d'un sentiment d'exaspération
partager à travers tout le continent
européen
en france l'hypothèse d'un troisième
confinement a pour l'heure provoquer de
vives contestations sur twitter avec le
hashtag je ne me confinerait pas
appelant à une désobéissance civile si
une telle décision était prise par le
gouvernement qui devrait préciser sa
stratégie cette semaine